Nicht nur ihr die klicks um zuschauer vermuten dass es sich beim
interstellaren objekt das durch unser sonnensystem gerast ist um ein fremdes raumschiff um ein alien raumschiff
handelt ein forschungsteam des breakthrough listen projektes will heute das weltgrößte
Bewegliche teleskop auf das interstellare objekt ausrichten um es abzuhören das team um den astronomie professor
Wille von der harvard university rechnet sich tatsächlich chancen aus von dort signale?
Zu empfangen alle infos dazu jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction herzlich willkommen
Es ist wirklich frappierend zum ersten mal wurde ein objekt beobachtet dass
Aus dem interstellaren raum gekommen ist und durch unser sonnensystem geflogen ist und dabei vollführt es noch ein
perfektes ringen bei manöver um unsere sonne
So wie wir menschen es mit satelliten um planeten in unserem sonnensystem machen und es hat noch eine ganz besondere
Und tatsächlich seltsame form die eines spiels oder eben eines raumschiffes zitat dieses ding ist sehr merkwürdig
Dass sagt carole white von der universität von hawaii das team der forscherin hat das objekt aufgrund von
Beobachtungsdaten näher beschrieben und es wirklich ziemlich spooky das team hat herausgefunden dass das objekt alle 7,3 stunden
Um seine eigene achse rotiert und dabei immer heller und wieder dunkler wird um das, zehnfache zitat
Diese ungewöhnlich starker helligkeit änderung deutet darauf hin dass das objekt sehr lang gezogen sein muss etwa zehnmal so lang wie breit
mit einer komplexen
gebundenen form
Erklärt die forscherin mit auch extrem seltsam das objekt hat eine farbe es ist rot und
Auch ihr habt vermutet dass es ein raumschiff ist rap bekamen 98 likes für diese einschätzung der lage zitat
Ich denke immer noch dass es ein raumschiff ist was vom galaxie
zu galaxie fliegt und sich die gravitation vom planeten zunutze
Macht um angetrieben zu werden ein zwingen bei manöver vermutet rap auch und das ist offenbar auch eine ansicht die
Astronomie teams teilen heute soll das green bank teleskop
Im us staat virginia zehn stunden lang auf vier verschiedenen funkübertragung bändern nach radiosignalen
Des objektes suchen das objekt ist inzwischen doppelt so weit von der erde entfernt wie die sonne es ist also noch relativ
Nah und es ist relativ einfach sechs schwache
signale zu empfangen dort signale zu finden wären für das forschungsteam
Nicht komplett ausgeschlossen, am zweiten september tauchte das interstellare objekt ja senkrecht
zudem umlaufbahnen der planeten in unserem sonnensystem zwischen sonne und merkur bayern ein
Die gravitation der sonder lenkte das objekt dann
Unterhalb der sonne in richtung erde um wo es unterhalb der erdumlaufbahn
Am 14 oktober an der erde vorbei führung inzwischen ist das objekt durch die umlenkung der sonne wieder über die planeten
Hinaus geschossen worden dabei wurde das objekt erst entdeckt als es schon an der erde vorbeigeflogen war am 18 oktober
2000 17 führte das
1,8 meter teleskop an stars 1 auf der hawaii-insel maui das objekt auf und dann ergaben die berechnungen
Des objektes sehr schnell dass es nicht von dieser. Welt war nicht von einem anderen planeten
Im sonnensystem und überhaupt nicht aus unserem sonnensystem es gab sogar noch überhaupt
keine kategorie für das objekt und weil es irrtümlich für einen asteroiden gehalten wurde bekam es erstmals die falsche bezeichnung a
2000 17 uhr 1 inzwischen hat die internationale astronomische union eine neue kategorie für interstellare objekte eingeführt
Ist jetzt die bezeichnet ist also jetzt 1 2017 u1 und hat auch einen hawaiianischen namen bekommen
Humor wenn es nicht so unglaublich unwahrscheinlich wäre könnte man es eben für ein raumschiff alten so extrem seltsam wie es aussieht
hinzukommt zitat
Außerdem konnten wir bestätigen dass es vollständig inaktiv ist weil wir in seiner direkten umgebung nicht den geringsten hinweis auf
staub finden konnten
berichtete mitch und das forschungsteam vermutet deshalb dass das fremde objekt aus gestein oder eben eine mix mit hohen metallanteil besteht
Das würde für ein raumschiff sprechen und anders als zunächst vermutet hatte es nicht einen durchmesser von 160 metern sondern war sogar
400 meter lang es ist ein wirklich wirklich seltsam als objekt also eben rund genug
Ist jetzt zu untersuchen allerdings schätzt das forschungsteam die chancen als gering ein tatsächlich
Signale von dem objekt zu empfang eine wahrscheinlichkeit gibt es zwar aber sie ist gering aber auch wenn keine signale von
Humor gesendet werden ist diese
attraktion heute nicht vergeblich das astronomie team erhofft sich auch weitere daten die aufschluss über die zusammensetzung
Des objektes geben ist es eher
Ja wieso ein asteroid aus stein oder eine art komet mit eis und staub ja wenn ihr also kein video zum
Aktuellen stand verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein abo aufsaugen vergesst nicht den
Auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr auch über die neuesten videos informiert hier geht es weiter und dafür einfach draufklicken mit dem ersten video
zur entdeckung des objektes sensation interstellare objekt rast durchs sonnensystem mit weiteren infos und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran